the Egyptian evidence does not give us a
personal picture of the Queen we do not
have hieroglyphs that tell us how she
interacted with Caesar what we do have
from the Egyptian evidence is how she is
portrayed as a monarch the temple of
dendera represents cleopatra at the
height of her power this is probably the
image of Cleopatra anywhere in Egypt
anywhere in the world Cleopatra as the
mother of caesarean whom she believes is
her rightful heir
these figures 20 feet high convey a
message he may have had a Roman father
but cesarean was an Egyptian
he was first and foremost his mother's
air here Cleopatra was telling the world
how she and Egypt had harnessed Rome's
power
she used religion to help make her point
appropriating one of the most important
Egyptian festivals she portrayed herself
as the goddess Hathor and Caesar as the
Falken god Horus
these representations of the two were
united in a ceremony that took place
along a 90 mile stretch of the nine
it revolves around the procession of
sacred boats one stationed here in
vendrá the Dendera boat carries the
female goddesses the boat from Ed fool
carries the male god Horus the mail boat
would depart for Dendera from the temple
at edfu
these two temples are a mirror of each
other they're essentially joined
Andrea Kay explores the ed food temple
its construction was only finished
during Cleopatra's reign
Cleopatra made very clear that she was
the goddess Hathor and it was also very
widely implied that Caesar was the King
Horace
so the statue of the god Horus
representing Caesar in this case would
have been placed in the bark which is
essentially a mobile shrine carried
among the people to the river and
transported to dendera where Hathor also
Cleopatra had the female portion this
was a piece of propaganda as much as a
religious ritual when Caesar and
Cleopatra came together she didn't
become Roman rather Caesar
took on an Egyptian identity